oh whoa I want to see it again alright
y'all so ever since my show started
there has been one thing that just seems
to keep popping up and that's tick-tock
what are you planning necks for
tick-tock are you on tick-tock you I'm
yes what you want to do something
together let's do one let's try and beat
25 million views I could do that no I am
slowly getting better at the app but if
anyone knows me they know I love a
competition and I want to be the best so
well who aims to lose right that's a
loser aims to lose so sometimes you lose
I can lose but I don't want to aim to
lose so anyway so today today I am
taking on three popular tick tock
challenges to see if I can in fact beat
out the teens let's do this I've got you
teens all right so I am not seeing these
videos I can 100% assure you that cuz I
have a lot of kids and jobs so here we
go okay this is the first challenge I've
moved the iPad to better lighting here
we go oh my god I got what she's doing
that's crazy
whoa at first I was like I'm not a
magician how am I supposed to do this
okay so then where do I look camera this
okay okay I think I know that
I think it did all right on the first
one I will say it wasn't like a big
pencil it's like a you know it's got
this little thing on it so I think I'm
gonna messed up with that but I don't
know but it's my favorite pencil so I
don't care
this is called the hand illusion
challenge shall we
Michelle let me see what you do Oh No I
want to see it again that was cool okay
wait I want to see it again so well oh
my god okay she was really good I'm okay
I'm feeling pressure on this okay I
can't have that cool music though okay
let me see if my hands are like bit okay
okay here we go oh oh I didn't know what
it was coming
well cuz I have to press it I have to
press play I'm thinking this is hard to
get press wait okay ready hon okay wait
ahhh I got better at it it was I had to
lead with the other hand oh you're
welcome
you're welcome
so I did B what is this calm I did the
emoji hand challenge before and I double
did it I was like what I've got like all
of it with two of my hey I was like
ambidextrous it was awesome apparently I
did the easy one
whatevs let me see what this one is okay
they're separate okay bragger I don't
think I can do that
wait let me I gotta practice wait you
can't even look at both in at the same
time how how much do these people
practice okay okay one hand oh my gosh
this is impossible this guy is an alien
how many people do this okay wait left
hand oh it's backwards
I felt so powerful before no no how do
you say that no I hate that that's
incredible talent let's let's maybe take
it easy on myths Clarkson in the
comments below how did he do it it was
just like and then the other one I got
this one this one was better when I
switched hands that was cool
Casey yeah I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this